do you remember what was the first thing
that we did with you do you remember
when we put you on camera obviously when
you work on this show you're involved in
a lot of Comedy bits playing various
characters that may come up so there
were plenty of those going all the way
back to the 90s But to answer your
question as I think you wanted it where
you were playing Jordan's where you were
yourself no I was playing um Man 2 in
the courtroom like that those Eclipse
exist I understand but but at a certain
point I believe
I think I took you out to dinner at one
point and we had a dinner remember that
was it I don't think it was the first
thing we did necessarily but that was a
moment where you and I went and had an
Italian dinner and people really got to
know you I think that's where the legend
of Jordan kind of really started to grow
you're skipping a couple of things but
that did happen what you're describing
did in fact okay but even if your
chronology is off okay why don't you
tell me because I'm ignorant what was
the first thing you did where you were
really just Jordan shlansky being
yourself okay in 2007 this is on the NBC
show we visited lucasfilm limited
headquarters in San Francisco okay I was
there in a production capacity
performing the tasks which apparently
you don't acknowledge that are performed
nevertheless I was there and ended up
being pulled into the remote itself yes
and I brought you in and probably there
was a spark there where people could see
this is an interesting fellow and Conan
has uh quite an interesting and somewhat
comedic Dynamic with this fellow which
probably led to us doing something else
what was the next thing so the next
thing was during the rider strike this
was the end of 2007 beginning of 2008
where it was there was really no premise
at all it was simply you and I sitting
in a room and having a conversation and
I think that led to certain situational
things that we had mentioned we had
tried some wine based on our initial
conversation you had rummaged through my
office and that was the first of many
Loosely structured ideas okay just to
remember and that you're aware this is
not a court deposition okay so you're
allowed to just chat uh and this you
know this is not gonna be this is not
going to be
there's no pressure here on you I don't
feel any pressure whatsoever for exact
dates and uh for you to defend yourself
presenting some context that's all okay
um
on to the next question
we do go to dinner and that's when
things I think really started to cook
people learned that you take great pride
in your knowledge of certain areas of
the good life Fine Wines okay well
yesterday I enjoy wine that's good I
don't claim to be any kind of expert on
a particular class of wine I just enjoy
drinking wine that's good okay you also
um like to
talk a lot about Italy I enjoy visiting
Italy and uh as a natural consequence of
that it may come up in conversation from
time to time it came up a lot many such
decisions I mean someone could uh you
know a gorilla could smash through the
door and start throwing coconuts at
people and you would turn that into a
discussion of Italy uh you you take
anything that happens and make it about
Italy and it's quite incredible and then
you love to create your knowledge about
Italy so I took you to Italy so that you
could show off I thought I was doing you
a favor was it not a favor that I took
you to Italy it was a fun vacation just
to be clear I'm not interested in
showing anything off I'm really
unconcerned as to what you may think of
my knowledge or lack thereof I simply
know what I know and when asked I say
what I know or as Popeye says I am what
I am so in a way you're an Italian
Popeye
listen I enjoy visiting Italy it's as
simple as that we don't need to kind of
extrapolate hidden meaning
there's no TV cameras rolling on this
right now okay it is just you and I
talking and yet the dynamic is unchanged
did you think the presence of the
television cameras was in some way
discouraging me from revealing what I do
to you in another way altering my
personality I I didn't know but I do
love that when you start to get angry
you get a maniacal grin your eyebrows
take this unnatural Arch much like the
Riddler when cornered by his foe the
Batman I'm sure you have your own way of
talking about the Batman that's more
accurate you'd probably call well
technically he's the Batman because in
1951 uh original Creator Bob Kane blah
blah blah but you get a maniacal look on
your puss this is my physical appearance
I maintain my Aesthetics as best as I
can if you'd like to devote some time to
exchanging comments about each other's
physical appearance I'm happy to do so
no I I I I don't want to do that I'd
like to take a second now and take a
little stroll down memory lane you like
a stroll down memory lane I'll go along
with this premise
[Laughter]
why it's just me we're buddies aren't we
buddies I'm completely relaxed I don't
know why there's an accusation that I'm
in some way per turn hahaha
you're like no one I've ever met you're
a complete you're a one-off
you're uh unusual occurrence in the time
space fabric people really do enjoy our
adventures together the remote segments
that we've done I thought we'd play a
couple okay here on the radio I want to
play one and I'm glad you seem thrilled
about it
uh here's one where we it's called the
espresso machine remote do you remember
this remote
I do remember it was a situation you
call it remote I call it part of my life
we had an espresso machine outside my
office and for some reason that turned
heads maybe it was the fact that it was
outside my office that just happened to
have been where there was an empty table
that's where the machine ended up I'm
sorry
it just happened to be out that's I
tolerate 80 of this but sometimes you
step over the line and you just did
Buddy Boy you purchased with show Money
a very expensive espresso machine and
then where did you put it it was for the
show why wouldn't it be with show money
I don't understand why this is so old
and then where did you put it you put it
right outside your office which was in
this very hard to reach tiny cul-de-sac
in our TBS office building you could
barely find it and you tucked it outside
a table that was conveniently right
outside your office and practically
inaccessible to anyone else most people
didn't even know it existed I don't
understand the relevance of the
geography of the office itself what does
it matter where the table was and what
particular quadrant of the office it was
available to everybody multiple people
know about it they couldn't even it's
not my responsibility to make people
would you expect some kind of
announcement just a reminder the
espresso machine is still here it would
have been nice if you told people that
you purchased with show money and
expensive espresso machine and put it
right outside your office which is a
dead end as many things with you are it
was a complete dead end and so no one
could even find that espresso machine I
once hired seven Baristas to Patrol
office and they couldn't find it it's
but he stay the plural of Barista is
Barista in Italian we don't pluralize by
adding an app I would slap if you were
you were Beyond I'm looking extending my
arm and you're be God that grinning
pumpkin of yours is beyond my reach or I
would slap you right now I would slap
you full across the the face